we're blown away. And it's just
certain moments throughout
the game that you just go, man.
How did he just do that? What
amazes you most watching him
play for? Hey, Christopher. The
crazy thing about when I watch
Aaron
Rodgers, it trips me out because
he sees everything and
he gets the ball out of his
hands so quickly. So he makes
it so difficult for a defense
to try to Blitz him to try to
disguise coverage and
it's just so tough. And every
time I see Aaron Rodgers
playing, this is all Only
quarterback that I've said this
about. Every time I see Aaron
Rodgers play, I say, wow. He
does something incredible. I
can't believe
in his relationship with Davante
Adams. It's that extra
sensory, perception that ESP
that telepathic, who just
turned out.
I just Googled it before the
broadcast, but they got that
telepathic communication route.
What makes that connection? So
unique. Well, the fan sit back
and they see the catches. They
see the numbers, they see two
touchdowns, but they don't
understand. All the work
that goes on behind the scenes.
Practice the meetings,
walkthroughs and things and
just to cover the Casual
conversations passing each
other
in the locker room.
And you knocked off a whole
bunch of Great Wide Receiver
quarterback combinations. How
would you try to defend that
duo? We get to some of these big
games in the playoffs, but
we talked about double coverage
and even the Minnesota Vikings
tried to double problem on the
first grade
and he still complete. I would
take my number one corner and
my number one safety
double-team. Him and force are
Rogers to go elsewhere with the
ball. You can A not allow
Davante Adams to have a big game
like you had tonight when
I look at this guy AJ Dillon,
right? You
got Dylan who's coming out of
the backfield, big power back
out of Boston. College loves his
applesauce. He'll be join
us here in just a second. We'll
ask him about all of the above.
But what element is? He brought
specifically
for cold weather football, which
is coming their way. Well
number one depth, you know, we
know Aaron Aaron Jones, why are
these people call him on a
cold it? All right.
I don't see one cold person.
They'll be here till 3:00 a.m.
If they let him. So, what's
the question again? JJ Dillon?
What's he brought to this
Packers toughness just depth. I
mean, you look think about 250
pounds in this weather. If we
saw in the fourth quarter in the
third quarter, when they
get a comfortable lead now, they
can lean on him. They can
run the football. We're defense
down and that's exactly what
happened today. And then you got
coach LaFleur who shorted
given just stability to this
whole operation and it wasn't
always
roses. His relationship with
Aaron Rodgers. Yes, but what is
that? Blossom into that
relationship? It's beautiful
because he knows and he
understands Aaron Rodgers. He
understands that unique
personality and he's a guy
that's getting the most out of
Aaron Rodgers. So if I'm Aaron
Rodgers, there's
no way I'm leaving the Green Bay
Packers.
Everything is set up perfectly
for you.
You got a really good offense of
line. You're getting a bunch
of guys back on defense. Your
defense is going to continue to
grow and get better. And of
course, you got the best wide
receiver in all of football and
Davante Adams. He think about
David back to Yari.
The back area. Smith coming
back. J here. Alexander coming
back.
Really three of their best
players. You look outside of
Aaron Rodgers. What will that
infusion of talent? Do come
playoff time, man? Let me tell
you, it's going to give them
a boost because, you know, at
times you see and you kind of
see a leaky
Packers defense and you start to
see them. Well, maybe
they're a little tired, but then
you get this level of
talent enthusiasm to come in.
It's going to be big for him
energy-wise. Hey, Chris Simms.
When you think about the whole,
NFC, all these teams. Now having
to
come into Lambo. So, who do you
see the can come beat this
group with the way? They're
playing down the homestretch?
Yeah, it's going to take a
special performance. And again,
listen, I'm not going to count
out Tampa Bay and Tom. Brady
certainly not right. I mean you
guys we've seen we've been
there done that. And of course
he's used to the cold weather
coming from New England, the
Dallas Cowboys. I'm still going
to put them in the mix there to
be one of those teams, you know
again just too
many great physical football
players
on both sides of the ball,
but I mean the list is it short,
it really is. I Probably
put the 49ers in that category,
maybe to a degree
but to go up to Green Bay.
Rogers knows this. I've had
these conversations with him. He
knows they're a different
team up there in January. When
the when the elements are in
their favor 10 degrees. He knows
he could still throw
laser beams all over the field.
It
doesn't matter if it's windy or
cold.
So whoever does come up there.
They're going to have their
hands full and you're gonna
have to play a perfect game as
far as execution is concerned.
I don't know if you guys heard
me in the opening. That's
the one thing. I'm Amazed by by
this Packers team. They remind
me a lot of like the Patriots
teams Rodney played on,
doesn't always just go. Wow.
Wow. Wow, but they never miss
up, Miss mess. The game up. They
execute in All Phases of
the football game. And that's
where they're really
impressive. Hey Chris, I got to
ask you then again. Did you say
the San Francisco 49ers
that you believe they can come
up here and beat the Green Bay
Packers in this weather. I'm
going to put them in a short.
Like I don't feel as confident
about. Maybe them is Tampa or
Dallas, but the way they Run the
football
and was Shanahan and his ability
to come up with game
plan plays, make the game easy
on the quarterback and
the other defense being a top 10
defense. I am Rodney. I'm going
to put them in that. I know I'm
probably in the minority in
that conversation, but
I like a lot of the things I see
that 49er team.
The only thing that I was kind
of hesitant on is because Jimmy
G. He has that injured hand,
right? Yeah. It's cold up here
and these guys are physical.
They get out the quarterback.
I'm gonna have to disagree with
you a little bit on that one.
Agree with you. On tampabay
Tampa Bay can definitely come up
here and play well and
I still believe in the Dallas
Cowboys ever. Do you think
about Tampa Bay? They've really
been weakened. Chris guy went
out of the lineup. We saw what
happened with Antonio Brown
today as well. Mike Evans
been battling a hamstring and
injected today talking about
it. You see from Tom after that
game titles detected. He was
dejected because he puts so much
effort and time and trying
to develop and trying to help
Antonio Brown out and for him
to be so selfish
like that and the kid needs
help. That's Tom's Ro spot on.
I mean, Thomas frustrated. Yeah.
And here in Green Bay. What's,
what has everybody so excited
those Championship expectations.
Just continue to
rise. It's because of this
defense. So when you watch this
Green Bay defense on the field,
rasul Douglas of midseason pick
up. They had. What is it that
catches
your eye about that day, you
know what? They have a lot of
lot of great, fantastic players.
I mean, start start up
front with Kenny, Clarke. I mean
the guys just been
absolutely dominating the
interior the defense. They try
to double-team this kid. They
trying to double-team him and
he breaks two tackles and then
you get
That pressure from the outside
za'darius Smith, you get
Rashawn Gary and then you get
za'darius Smith coming back
during the playoffs. They're
going to be very tough to deal
with. And we haven't even talked
about, Zaya are
Alexander the All-Pro cornerback
that just gives them more depth
depth at the most important
place of some novel Pro. As
much as these fears are yelling
my name, I'm still focused.
This might be the
only group of fans there. We
have a postgame show.